[Music]
almost two full minutes of opening
credits set over a visual aid that would
make the original Beauty and the Beast
blush and this even came out the same
year poor Kevin Reynolds even this
bastard tombstone will read was finished
by Kevin Costner reading just like Errol
Flynn's version of this tale of
merriment and romance we begin of course
with a brutal scene of torture this is
English courage accent because that
stuff's apparently for suckers seriously
no one's pulled their hand back from the
chopping block
even bro flexibly daddy deliv got us
kill to eat otherwise we'd get along no
man deserves to die in there except for
all those other guys robbed and
immediately gave up on liberating but he
could have gotten the keys to the
shackles from the dead guards right and
even if he didn't have time to
personally unlock them he could have
tossed them to the prisoners right right
what if I say no
Robin has one yellow fruit in his left
hand here and two green ones in his
right but the next captures two yellow
fruits in his left arm oh also a movie I
probably wouldn't even notice or care if
you hadn't gone so far out of your way
to show them voraciously eating one of
these fruits a moment ago definitely
good we'll overcome
trust in that discount Orson Welles
seems awfully sure but also this is a
movie so yes I'm choosing to believe
that good will overcome Wow Robin's dad
just happens to be killed on the exact
same night he escaped prison after five
years what are the odds
nonsense everyone knows Snape wasn't
actually a Death Eater premature
celebration I cannot to dishonor them I
thought you'd say that
who the hell are these assholes that
agreed to this plan it's not like Robin
had any money to give them for capturing
Azim and even if he promised them some
were they gonna follow him all the way
to his estate also why does Robin have
such a boner for getting rid of Azim
anyway and why do it now
after you've come all the way to jolly
old England was a zine necessary to
navigate this journey by nightfall we
will celebrate with my father
[Music]
many imagi resolved to me thanks to this
little plant don't make a Bill Cosby
joke don't make a bill cosby joke don't
make up dudes back in England for all of
50 seconds and he's already come across
the convenient England has got an evil
chase we're a bunch of knights tried to
kill a child wait that's your best plan
there are like six grown men here at
least one of whom has to be able to
climb a tree that a kid just scaled how
long would it take to cut this thick ass
tree down with a battle ax if you'd be
so kind as to give me your name before I
run yes sir he's Kevin Costner really
trying the British accent now it's like
20 minutes into the movie dude you don't
sound like you're from London you
traveled 10,000 miles to save my life
and leave me to be butchered even if
Robins being hyperbolic here that's way
the hell off
Jerusalem is barely 3,000 miles from the
middle of England and Robin was just
bragging about his geographical prowess
a couple minutes ago you whine like a
mule wow this is far ahead of Morgan
Freeman's ascension to godlike status he
is still better than this and I have to
sit in the movie for it and then it
wouldn't matter no point during that
encounter did Robin have a hood on it
looks like there may be a hood on his
cloak but you could just as easily have
called him a cloaked man all right guy
with a English accent whatever you were
just pissed that your cousin interrupted
your sexing this lady but the college
hunks hauling junk don't get any higher
for waltzing in here with a fucking
statue during boner time Yahtzee
question are the stray pieces of
eggshell part of the mystic recipe or
does the spell just not get ruined if
egg shells end up in the mix asking for
a friend also seriously what's the deal
with this movie what's the central idea
to take the Robin Hood mythology and
make it as grisly and gross as possible
even the Russell Crowe version wasn't
this gross and that was grimy so grimy
it even had Scott rhymes
man he haunts my dreams that's racist
no Skeletor also Costner enjoyed the put
the prisoner in a hanging metal cage and
leave them to die thing here so much he
reused it in Waterworld this is as good
of a spot as any to ask can we talk
about Kevin Costner's mullet in this
movie I know this was made in the 90s
when Billy Ray Cyrus walked the earth as
a star but who decided the mullet was
the de facto haircut for the hero of a
medieval epic did you believe in charges
even when they took my eyes so Duncan's
been living at the burndown castle since
las Lee died but how it's been around
for months since the sheriff attacked so
what has he been eating it's not like he
could even forage for food
my mother is blowing hospitality in this
country is as warm as the weather
and yet you're the best dressed for cold
weather of all three dudes in your birdy
almost like 40 percent of your lines
were lifted from a party jokes about the
British coffee table book next you'll be
ribbing Robin about calling his
apartment a flat or enjoying tea oh yeah
I am the maid Marion well then show
yourself child for we knew each other
well man what is up with his ruse Robin
said it's only been six years since he
and Peter left for the Crusades Mary
Elizabeth mastrantonio was in her early
30s when she played Marion sub Shana
spring chicken and wouldn't have been a
young child when Robin left and
apparently he was over here all the time
so it's not like she would have
forgotten his ass Marion like all maids
and 1168 I presume there's a combat
badass but Marion was just trying to
straight-up kill Robin just a second ago
now that she's got him incapacitated
she's just gonna stand there also I
probably should have just said Marion
his addictive Robin's balls you and my
brother are off playing boy heroes
Nottingham has plundered the show you
killed the hobbits running away while
struggling to act like you mean it has
found its poster child record scratch
hold the fuck up he burned her hair as a
kid man Robin of Loxley he's a
psychopath he's Tyrians bug smashing
cousin
in the 12th century it was common to
stack piles of hay everywhere because
you honestly never knew which wall you
were going to need to jump from suddenly
[Music]
they're already here
so is this supposed to make Guy of
Gisbourne want to kill them harder in
one move robbing is addictive horses and
stone walls
goddamn I love the score so much Michael
Kaman was the best and I'm gonna take
off a possum of synonyms honor shall
advise to taunt it master either we take
our chances with the ghost who become
ghosts ourselves Oh Kevin I think we've
established very early on the only
person in this movie who can beat this
overdramatic is Alan Rickman wait what
this is how Robin gets his Hood name
just from some guy screaming at him like
a weird man after Untouchables that's
two movies within four years were a bad
guys right-hand man taunt Kevin
Costner's character by telling him
someone he loved died squealing like a
stuck pig
this is like that thing about spider-man
movies mentioning branzino cannot be a
coincidence right will is definitely
singing the melody of pop goes the
weasel which wasn't written until the
mid 1850s so maybe more anachronistic
than Jesus on a cross reading a blog
article about black holes on an iPad
cross these are outlaws and refugees
from the evil reign of Nottingham in a
haunted forest most men don't enter and
they spend their days hiding along this
river at this very spot just in case
some asshole comes walking through here
who might have money they can demand as
a toll get the fuck out of here with
this shit just say you wanted a River
fight and be done with it it's gonna
cost you that gold medallion that is not
a gold medallion there is very little
gold colored metal on this thing no one
would look at this and call it a gold
medallion
if you English ever need a reason why we
think you talk weird just look to this
line alone for your answer
ya know rappin got lit up rolled off the
waterfall and downstream long before
Little John could even get out to this
rock no anyway he swam against a strong
current completely underwater and popped
out at the exact location to take John
out also for those of you scoring at
home and you know we are that's two nut
shots in the last 12 minutes Robin Hood
has roughly the same joke frequency as
an illumination movie at while hero
being offended a tiny bounty on her head
cliche I see the boy I knew
in the men before me okay let's talk
about the eight thing again kevin
costner was also no spring chicken at
this point in his mid to late 30s and
again it's only been six years since he
left so he should be easily identifiable
as an adult okay
[Music]
this is a great line so great that it
distracts the archers that are right
there from actually shooting that Robin
until he can respond then it begins I
can't wait until he foils the sheriff
and the climax of the movie and says he
rented the lesson calling back to this
fart where he pointed out the lessons
beginning movie totally yadda yadda is
how Robin got down from the roof of that
bill oh wait there's probably a big pile
of hay on the ground never mind I love
how Robin gets beyond the gate on a
horse and the chase is just over
where's boys it's not like we have any
horses that could write we do have
horses it's too late now discussion
about whether or not we had horses
allowed him five more seconds of late
time making it useless to give chase
curses thankfully that's sack he grabbed
back in town to smack the gate guard and
the feast with had food in it he could
share with the Lost Boys of the hood
here instead of trash or dung or a bunch
of wadded up unused other burlap sacks
Tonka
breath here non this hilariously large
loaf of bread that could easily feed
several people in our community forget
yourself Ozzie my do not ask for your
company or council man well these do
just fuckin get it over with
well perhaps we could create a name for
him man look I love Michael Wincott and
he's awesome in this movie but the way
that he's shot is so disruptive Lee
close up that I'm about to vomit every
time he comes on screen now so keep the
stitches small but definitely don't wipe
off the blood or clean the area of the
wound first just stitch away as is you
twit the director said let's have your
character eat an apple not because we
need him to look like more of an asshole
he's doing fine at that
but because craft services bunch of
nitwits ordered a thousand apples
delivered to the set because they
thought we were filming that big horse
scene today but we're not so we're
trying to find creative ways to use the
apples before they go bad since we paid
for them up front there's your mate a
man they call little he died last winter
burn it down Wow Robin Hood Prince of
Thieves is basically Untouchables meets
the patriot and it's blowing my mind I
guess as long as they don't later pour
molten metal into revenge molds for
weaponization wait they do that to
village recently burned Wow just come to
the secret hideout in the haunted woods
that apparently everyone knows the way
to and no one is fooled by the haunted
stare a beacon here broadcasting on a
frequency everyone but Nottingham's
people can hear it's literally the most
commonly found unfindable place in all
of film history this is like half the
Gotham press walking into the Batcave
yelling Bruce Bruce question you brought
this misery on us Locksley it's nothing
I'm trying to divide us why not both
Wow would you look at that Robins a
crack shot with a bow and arrow it's not
weird at all that they waited over a
hour into the movie to show us that he
could do that how does his Eames curved
sword sheath work the swords skinnier at
the hilt than at the tip yet somehow
slides through this sheath that is also
skinnier at the hill legit exactly how
long this training session lasts the
movie doesn't say for good reason
because they train these clueless
farmers up to Kingsguard level in a
matter of hours instead of the years it
would really take even if I accept your
hyper speed blacksmithing which I do not
where did you assholes get all the route
metal to meltdown for these swords in
the first place cool shot and all but
we've seen what pains these villagers
take to make every single arrow so
Robins clearly being a dick here just to
show how accurate he is he's an outlaw
horse he rides
Robins wanted we reckon is me three to
four million in the last five I take
issue with the numbers here first of all
all five months even being generous
there's no way train that ambush army in
five months second three to four million
what pounds did the pound exist in 1168
three or four million in gold coins no
more merciful beheadings and call off
Christmas look I could do this in a
million places in this movie but if I
don't go ahead and take off a sin for
Alan Rickman's ridiculously good
performance I'm not gonna respect myself
in the morning do my room 10:30 tonight
you 10:45 bring a friend I guess the
joke is that nodding ham is overly horny
or that he has no stamina or that he
schedules meetings for his dick like a
secretary filling the day for her boss
if the movie would pick one lane for
this character I could maybe keep up
what's the purpose of this procession
I thought all of gisbourne's men were
scared of the forest and if they're on a
search for Robin why are they bringing
this massive amount of beer this works
and he's also not trampled to death on
accident
the hell is this crap l-'azim doesn't
even know who he killed in the carriage
and he could easily have killed Robin
there's a reason this scene wasn't in
the theatrical cut of the movie but why
was it shot at all for this well at
least I didn't use a spoon god damn this
is some cold ass to say to your cousin
before he dies like we know Nottingham's
a dick but this is some Jules Winnfield
double trash talk and for a forest where
no one went before Robin got here super
populated with tourists the hell is
Marian out here at all
Marian accidentally seeing naked Robin
swimming is not necessary she already
likes him and wants to help and this
nudity is long distance
who gets horny from nudity this far away
except for God yep you definitely could
have said you also could have taken them
to the main village and had them wait
we're really anywhere else in the forest
and they wouldn't have known what you
were doing but apparently there was such
a demand for hot Costner ass that we
needed to bring the women here
yeah wolf missed the target but he hit
this asshole in the neck if anything
that will kill him faster right
contribution to your cause dagger
shadowing how would Robin have gotten
down if Marian were here they're going
slowly enough that it's clearly balanced
just enough for the two of them so he
would have been hanging up there in
midair all I know is that our last words
in this world are spoken in anger now a
movie is cribbing from Field of Dreams
as well I'm legit starting to wonder if
Robin Hood Prince of Thieves is actually
not a movie but instead some sort of
super long term experiment on human
perception to discern when movies are
similar the same or just looking
identical men speak conveniently of love
I know right it's almost like there's no
love like your Allah and no other could
give more love no Prince of Thieves roll
of the credits your baby has not turned
Bonnie guard nag mother wisecracker and
Midwife Azim is literally the most
consistently surprising character in the
history of film no one will be seated
during the unnecessary and overly long
primitive c-section portion of the movie
I have this dance
Alice will Ben this whole time we've
seen every other villager in the montage
is in the group shots but he's just now
showing up to Mack on Robins lady yep
what we were definitely missing from the
theatrical version was the fleshing out
of the hiring the Celts to help out with
the Robin problem plotline of the movie
cat jump-scares are similarly in horror
movies and Kevin Costner movies they're
doubly sinful
I need you revised old Frank Christ even
the fucking horse knows how to get to
the secret camp in the Haunted Woods
this battle is literally 50% Braveheart
and 50% the Battle of Endor man if
someone could explain where these
characters are and how they teleport
from land to trees in the space of the
scene they deserve an honorary PhD my
god say hey why did not nm lead with the
fire attack it seems super useful the
main problem with the scene is that
they're in a goddamn forest and yet the
flaming arrows fly on target with no
impediment as to the wholly impractical
projectile shot from the catapults
despite you know being in the goddamn
forest fanny not only is this the most
convenient rope in the history of ropes
it also must be on a zipline or
something for Robin to get all the way
from where he was - right here
search your heart my child and while
you're there you might as well search
your soul and when you find me no more
this is a fine way to trick Marian into
thinking Robin is dead but how long did
you have to wait for the fires to burn
out before going back into the
battlefield and how long after that did
it take his ass to find this very
specific needle in a burned leaf
haystack God the idea that someone
lingered found that and knew it was
Robin's it's just infuriating among
these children to grow up as my allies
allows them to no choice
look God bent over the sheriff's
strategy a few times and I even started
doing oh let's talk about Nottingham's
plan sin but just about everything that
happens is logical and he does execute a
great plan with ruthless efficiency
which was all brought about by Robin's
request for Marian to write to Richard
so why do we have to include the double
worshipping and the ping witch and on my
screen movie ah just like Errol Flynn's
version of this tale of merriment and
romance we begin the final act of course
with a brutal scene of torture what I
want to know is you gonna finish what
you've started King will man isn't he a
little too old for this teen angst I
mean who even has that haircut in
medieval England our Father loves you
more than me makes everything more the
same what a stupid twist I have more
reason to hate you than anyone if you
say so like literally you are simply
saying so I guess I believe you I think
Duncan had it rougher than you the last
six months but what do I know we
finished this so let me get this
straight
Nottingham believe will when he said he
could get close to Robin lashed him if
you
then let him go without anyone following
him this is a dude who executed this
last plan flawlessly and this is a much
easier mission
we've only seen the principal since the
attack and we're definitely led to
believe that they were the only
survivors d'movie seriously just invent
a fanny granny to yada-yada the infant
being safe it's actually pretty clever
how they infiltrate the castle and
distribute the weapons and you can tell
this with wall plant but it also depends
on none of the town's folk to say
anything about the unusual like swords
dropping right out of the sky this movie
is big on moments and short on logic
that guy's going to either live to tell
about the outlaw who threw him off the
wall or he's dead and probably someone
saw him draw fur we'll discover his dead
body soon you're supposed to be sneaking
in here but oh well bring them out now a
last-minute execution rescue like
Pirates of the Caribbean man I've been
dogging this movie for how many other
movies it feels like but maybe this
movie just deserves some credit for
doing a bunch of cool that other movies
have been trying to copy for decades man
everyone was cross surfing in the 90s um
where's will and the last shot we see
that he's tied to the powder keg on the
left of the gallows but here he's
apparently either a free man or a ghost
what the castles under attack the
prisoners aren't going anywhere so maybe
have the executioner try and take out
some of the actual threat hey it's the
iconic shop from the movie poster but
this background fire was way smaller
just a second ago movie suddenly and
preposterous Lee becomes a lethal weapon
film King hey of course there was hey
there it's a everywhere in this universe
hey man pre-teen me love the inclusion
of a subtle f-bomb in a movie I could
watch but this sets the precedent for a
million pg-13 movies from Mission
Impossible fallout 2 ocean's 8 to
shoehorn in one of these just because
they can do you madyun of the house of
Dubois take this man to be your lawfully
wedded husband yes of course she does if
they're gonna play fast and loose with
the rules here when I go through this
exercise at all not like the bishop
hasn't lied before on the sheriff's back
it belonged to your father using the
same sword to kill the father and son
and or using dead father's sword to kill
son cliche man for a swordsman Robin
sure is a good Archer
[Music]
Alan Rickman's the best but this debt
scene is straight out of a parody of
over dramatic death scene I would die
for you I mean she knows it's true
everything he do he do it for you hold I
speak
man for an English King Richard's
Scottish is Bryan Adams
because it's dull you twit
and crawl to freedom through 500 yards
of smelling foul as I can't even imagine
dagger I see before me nobody makes me
bleed my own blood deeper and deeper
into a state of complete relaxation
[Music]
you could kiss me on the veranda lips
would be fine
what do you see
[Music]
[Applause]